so there's about seven and a half
billion of us the World Health
Organization tells us that 300 million
of us are depressed and about 800,000
people take their lives every year a
tiny subset of them choose a profoundly
nihilistic route which is they die in
the act of killing as many people as
possible these are some famous recent
examples and here's a less famous one it
happened about nine weeks ago if you
don't remember it it's because there's a
lot of this going on Wikipedia just last
year counted 323 mass shootings in my
home country the United States not all
their shooters were suicidal not all of
them were maximizing their death tolls
but many many were an important question
becomes what limits to these people have
take the Vegas shooter he slaughtered 58
people did he stop there because he'd
had enough no and we know this because
he shot and injured another 422 people
who he surely would have preferred to
kill we have no reason to think he would
have stopped at 4,200 in fact was
somebody this nihilistic he may well
have gladly killed us all we don't know
what we do know is this
when suicidal murderers really go all in
technology is the force multiplier
here's an example several years back
there was a rash of 10 math school
attacks in China carried out with things
like knives and hammers and cleavers
because guns are really hard to get
there by macabre coincidence this last
attack occurred just hours before the
massacre in Newtown Connecticut but that
one American attack killed roughly the
same number of victims as the ten
Chinese attacks combined so we can
fairly say Knife terrible gun way worse
an airplane massively worse as pilot
andreas lubitz showed when he forced a
hundred and forty nine
people to join him and his suicide
smashing a plane into the French Alps
and there are other examples of this and
I'm afraid there are far more deadly
weapons in our near future than
airplanes one's not made of metal so
let's consider the apocalyptic dynamics
that will ensue if suicidal mass murder
hitches a ride on a rapidly advancing
field that for the most part holds
boundless promise for society somewhere
out there in the world there's a tiny
group of people who would attempt
however ineptly
to kill us off and they could just
figure out how the Vegas shooter may or
may not have been one of them but was
seven and a half billion of us this is a
nonzero population there's plenty of
suicidal nihilists out there we've
already seen that there's people with
severe mood disorders that they can't
even control they're people who have
just suffered deranging traumas etc etc
as for the corollary group its size was
simply zero forever until the Cold War
when suddenly the leaders of two global
alliances attained the ability to blow
up the world the number of people with
actual doomsday buttons has stayed
fairly stable since then but I'm afraid
it's about to grow and not just a three
this is going off the charts I mean it's
gonna look like a tech business plan and
the reason is we're in the era of
exponential technologies which routinely
take eternal impossibilities and make
them the actual super powers of one or
two living geniuses and this is the big
part then defuse those powers to more or
less everybody now here's a benign
example if you wanted to play checkers
with a computer in 1952 you literally
had to be that guy
then commandeer one of the world's
nineteen copies of that computer then
use your Nobel adjacent brain to teach
it checkers that was the bar today you
just need to know someone who knows
someone who
owns a telephone because computing is an
exponential technology so is synthetic
biology which I'll now refer to as sin
bio and in 2011 a couple of researchers
it's something every bit is ingenious
and unprecedented as the checkers trick
with h5n1 flu this is a strain that
kills up to 60 percent of the people it
infects more than Ebola but it is so
uncontained it's killed fewer than 50
people since 2015 so these researchers
edited h5n1 genome and baited every that
is deadly but also wildly contagious the
news arm of one of the world's top two
scientific journals said if this thing
got out it would likely cause a pandemic
with perhaps millions of deaths and dr.
Paul Keim said he could not think of an
organism as scary is this which is the
last thing I personally want to hear
from the chairman of the National
Science Advisory Board on biosecurity
and by the way dr. chyme also said this
and he's also one of these now the good
news about the 2011 bio hack is that the
people who did it didn't mean us any
harm their viral gist they believed they
were advancing science the bad news is
that technology does not freeze in place
and over the next few decades their feet
will become trivially easy in fact it's
already way easier because as we learned
yesterday morning just two years after
they did their work the CRISPR system
was harnessed for genome editing this
was a radical breakthrough that makes
gene editing massively easier so easy
that CRISPR is now taught in high
schools and this stuff is moving quicker
than computing that slow stodgy white
line up there that's Moore's law that
shows us how quickly computing is
getting cheaper that steep crazy fun
green line that shows us how quickly
genetic sequencing is getting cheaper
now gene editing
and synthesis and sequencing there
different disciplines but they're
tightly related and they're all moving
in these headlong rates and the keys to
the kingdom are these tiny tiny data
files that is an excerpt of h5n1 s
genome the whole thing can fit on just a
few pages and you know don't worry you
can google it as soon as you get home
it's all over the internet right and the
part that made it contagious could well
fit on a single post-it note and once a
genius makes a data file any idiot can
copy it distribute it worldwide or print
it and I don't just mean print it on
this but soon enough on this so let's
imagine a scenario let's say it's 20 26
to pick an arbitrary year and a
brilliant fire ologist hoping to advance
science and better understand pandemics
designs a new bug it's as contagious as
chickenpox it's as deadly as Ebola and
it incubates for months and months
before causing an outbreak so the whole
world can be infected before the first
sign of trouble
then her University gets hacked and of
course this is not science fiction
in fact just one recent u.s. indictment
documents the hacking of over 300
universities so that file with the bugs
genome on it spreads to the Internet's
dark corners and once a files out there
it never comes back just ask anybody who
runs a movie studio or a music label so
now maybe in 2026 it would take a true
genius like our biologists to make the
actual living critter but 15 years later
and they just take a DNA printer you can
find at any high school and if not give
it a couple of decades so a quick aside
remember this slide here turn your
attention to these two words if somebody
tries this and is only 0.1% effective
eight million people die that's 2,500
911s
civilization would survive but it would
be permanently disfigured so this means
we need to be concerned about anybody
who has the faintest shot on goal not
just geniuses so today there's a tiny
handful of geniuses who probably could
make a doomsday bug that's 0.1%
effective and maybe even a little bit
more they tend to be stable and
successful and so not part of this group
so I guess I'm sort of kind of barely
okayish with that but what about after
technology improves and diffuses and
thousands of life science grad students
are enabled are every single one of them
gonna be perfectly stable or how about a
few years after that when every stress
ridden premed is fully enabled at some
point in that timeframe these circles
are going to intersect whose are now
starting to talk about hundreds of
thousands of people throughout the world
and they recently included that guy who
dressed up like the Joker and shot 12
people to death at a Batman premiere
that was a neuroscience PhD student with
an NIH grant ok plot twist I think we
can actually survive this one if we
start focusing on it now and I say this
having spent countless hours
interviewing global leaders in san bio
and also researching their work for
science podcast I create I have come to
fear their work in case I haven't gotten
that out there yes but more than that to
revere its potential this stuff will
cure cancer heal our environment and
stop our cruel treatment of other
creatures so how do we get all this
without you know annihilating ourselves
first thing like it or not sin bio is
here so let's embrace the technology if
we do a tech ban that would only hand
the wheel to bad actors unlike nuclear
programs biology can be practiced
invisibly massive Soviet cheating on bio
weapons treaties made that very clear as
does every illegal drug law
in the world secondly enlists the
experts let's sign them up and make more
of them for every million in one
bioengineers we have at least a million
of them are going to be on our side
I mean Al Capone would be on our side in
this one the bar to being a good guy is
just so low and when massive numerical
advantages do matter even when a single
bad guy can inflict grievous harm
because among many other things they
allow us to exploit the hell out of this
we have years and hopefully decades you
know to prepare and prevent the first
person to try something off on there
will be somebody may not even be born
yet
next this needs to be an effort that
spans society and all of you need to be
a part of it because we cannot ask a
tiny group of experts to be responsible
for both containing and exploiting
synthetic biology because we already
tried that with a financial system and
our stewards became massively corrupted
as they figured out how they could cut
corners inflict massive massive risks on
the rest of us and privatize the games
becoming repulsively wealthy while they
stuck us with the 22 trillion dollar
bill and more recently are you the ones
who've gotten the thank-you letters I'm
still waiting for mine I just figured
they were too busy to be grateful and
much more recently online privacy
started looming as a huge issue in
basically outsourced debt and once again
privatized gains socialized losses is
anybody else sick of this pattern
so we need a more inclusive way to
safeguard our prosperity our privacy and
soon our lives so how do we do all this
well when bodies fight pathogens they
use ingenious immune systems which are
very complex and multi-layered when we
build one of these for the whole damn
ecosystem there's a year of TED Talks
that could be given on this first
critical layer so these are just a
couple of many great ideas that are out
there some R&D muscle could take the
very primitive pathogen sensors that we
currently have and put them on a very
steep price performance curve that
quickly become ingenious and networked
and gradually is widespread
as smoke detectors and even smartphones
on a very related note vaccines have all
kinds of problems when it comes to
manufacturing and distribution and once
they're made they can't adapt to new
threats or mutations we need an agile
bio manufacturing base extending into
every single pharmacy and maybe even our
homes printer technology for vaccines
and medicines is within reach if we
prioritize it next mental health many
people who commit suicide amass murder
suffer from crippling
treatment-resistant depression or PTSD
we need noble researchers like Rick
Doblin working on this but we also need
the selfish jerks who are way more
numerous to appreciate the fact that
acute suffering will soon endanger all
of us not just those afflicted those
jerks will then join us and Al Capone in
fighting this condition third each and
every one of us can be and should be a
white blood cell in this immune system
suicidal mass murderers can be
despicable yes but they're also terribly
broken and sad people and those of us
who aren't need to do what we can to
make sure nobody goes on love
next we need to make fighting these
dangers core to the discipline of
synthetic biology there are companies
out there that at least claim they let
their engineers spend 20% of their time
doing whatever they want what if those
who hire bio engineers and become them
give 20% of their time to building
defenses for the common good not a bad
idea right then finally this won't be
any fun but we need to let our minds go
to some very very dark places and thank
you for letting me take you there this
evening we survived the Cold War because
every one of us understood and respected
the danger in part because we had spent
decades telling ourselves terrifying
ghost stories with names like dr.
Strangelove and wargames this is no time
to remain calm this is one of those rare
times when it's incredibly productive to
freak the hell out to come up with some
ghost stories and use our fear as fuel
to fight this danger because all these
terrible scenarios I've painted they are
not destiny they're optional the disc
danger is still kind of distant and that
means it will only befall us if we allow
it to let's not thank you very much for
listening
[Applause]